because gasoline prices are going up
again the national average for a gallon
of regular Rose to almost
3.90 yesterday the average is much
higher in California up to 639 a gallon
after the worldwide oil cartel OPEC plus
decided to tighten its Supply Jonathan
Vigliotti is one of the millions paying
those high gas prices in California
sorry Jonathan he joins us from North
Hollywood good morning to you
and good morning to you Dana I prefer to
drive around on empty until my husband
fills up the tank it's a pretty good
trick here in LA county it is normal to
pay Seven to even eight dollars a gallon
for gas that easily adds up to around
100 for your typical mid-size car to
help ease the pain the state now issuing
gas rebates and for Millions it can't
come soon enough
that's a lot of money and it's way too
expensive gas prices are on the rise
again it's tough to live in LA right now
but in California it's on a whole other
level where prices have soared one
dollar and 15 cents in the past month
we've never seen the gap between
California and the rest of the country
this high this price spike comes after
several California oil refineries shut
down for maintenance limiting supplies
of gasoline it's not just California a
total of six western states are
averaging more than five dollars a
gallon and some midwest states are also
seeing an increase as they face Refinery
issues as well but now prices may rise
in all parts of the U.S after OPEC plus
led by Saudi Arabia decided to cut oil
production
disappointment leading President Biden
having to defend his visit to Saudi
Arabia this summer which was in part
intended to convince Saudi leaders to
support a boost in oil production
[Music]
the trip was not essentially for oil the
trip was about the Middle East and about
Israel with gas prices going up as
Americans enter the voting booth it
could be a stark reminder that gas
prices are very high priority for your
average American
and starting this morning here in
California some 23 million residents
will get those rebates they're linked to
income and the size of family some
households could receive more than one
thousand dollars Nate
Jonathan thank you